mes chers amis vous venez de toute la
france
vous êtes le peuple de france
vous êtes le peuple libre qui veut
tourner la page de 30 ans de renoncement
et de défaitisme
vous êtes le peuple libre qui veulent le
retour de la france l'ont tous ici nous
ne sommes pas tourner vers notre passé
nous sommes tournés vers notre avenir
nous voulons un espoir pour nos enfants
un emploi une vie sur une éducation
solide
le mérite est pas cet égalitarisme
socialiste de la réforme des collèges
que nous combattons farouchement depuis
le premier jour
merci aux 300 parlementaires et aux plus
de 30 mille signataires de mon appel au
retrait de cette réforme
le combat pour le mérite le combat pour
la maîtrise des savoirs le combat pour
la reconnaissance des talents continue
merci à tous ceux qui refusent les coups
de menton du pouvoir socialiste qui
recule devant la cgt mais qui passe en
force sur tout le reste
jamais françois hollande a écouté les
familles sur la loi taubira jamais
françois hollande n'a écouté les
médecins sur la suppression du tiers
payant généralisé et jamais françois
hollande n'a écouté ni les enseignants
ni les parents d'élèves sur la réforme
du collège car le gouvernement de
françois hollande est un gouvernement du
mépris françois hollande françois
hollande ose tout françois hollande est
indifférent à tout françois hollande
rabaisse tout jusque sur les marches du
panthéon
il a fait de la politique politicienne
monsieur hollande on ne récupère pas des
gloires et des souffrances qui
appartiennent à tous pour son profit
personnel en 2017 en 2017 nous en
finirons avec cette caste socialiste qui
ce soutien se cooptent et se protègent
en 2017 nous en finirons avec le
sectarisme de la gauche et en 2017 nous
en finirons avec françois hollande
contre le sectarisme de la gauche nous
voulons restaurer un esprit public
contre le sectarisme la gauche
nous voulons retrouver le sens du bien
commun et de l'intérêt général
mais notre combat notre combat ne doit
pas être un combat contre les
socialistes
il doit être un combat contre les idées
les socialistes notre combat ne doit pas
être contre les membres du gouvernement
il doit être contre les projets du
gouvernement
car on se grandit dans les débats
d'idées et on s'abîme dans les conflits
de personnes
oui nous devons faire tomber les murs de
la pensée socialiste sous la domination
desquels nous vivons depuis 30 ans à bas
le fatalisme
à bas la résignation de ce qu'ils en
pensent avoir tout essayé contre le
chômage alors que depuis 30 ans nous
essayons la même chose
à bas la culture de l'excusé pour les
délinquants
à bas la dictature égalitaire qui
prétend combattre les inégalités mais
qui les aggrave
qui prétend aider les plus faibles mais
qui enferme les plus faibles dans la
reproduction sociale
à bas la folie des taxes à bas la folie
des impôts
à bas la folie de la dépense publique
qui ravage la france depuis 30 ans à bas
la culture des droits sans les devoirs à
bas la protection des squatteurs contre
les propriétaires légitimes
abah abah la mauvaise conscience qui
ronge notre nation depuis des décennies
à bas la relecture inquisitoriale de
notre histoire nationale
on peut être lucide sur ses fautes et
fière de son histoire
on peut connaître vichy et rappeler la
résistance
on peut connaître les crimes de la
délation et ne pas oublier le visage de
ces jeunes de 20 ans tombé sous les
balles pour avoir défendu notre honneur
et notre liberté
on peut parler de la colonisation et se
souvenir qu'en février 2003
une seule nation s'est opposé à la
guerre en irak
un seul homme a dit non et cette tâche
ont fêté la france et cet homme c'était
jacques chirac
bontemps si si vous êtes libre retour
ici pour croyez dans la france
alors faisons tomber les murs qui nous
empêche de vivre libre et de boue
faisant tomber les murs de cette classe
politique qui ne se renouvellent jamais
vous buter contre les mêmes visages
nous allons vous offrir de nouveaux
visages vont buter contre les mêmes
idées nous allons vous offrir de
nouvelles idées à tous les jeunes et les
moins jeunes
tipiak ici du désir de servir la france
je veux dire vous êtes impatients vous
avez raison vous porter une ambition
nouvelle pour la france
vous avez raison vous voulez le pouvoir
vous avez raison mais alors prenez le
parce qu'on à vous le donnera jamais
prenez modèle sur ces nouveaux élus de
mars 2014 et de mars 2015 sur toute
cette nouvelle génération de
responsables locaux qui ont forcé leur
destin et qui font la fierté notre
mouvement
prenez modèle sur la france qui ne se
résignent pas prenez modèle sur la
france dont on ne parle jamais la france
qui travaille la france qui se bat la
franche modeste qui tend la main aux
plus faibles
la france du courage la france de la
dignité
prenez modèle sur ces femmes qui élèvent
seules leurs enfants et qu'ils préfèrent
se battre pour tous et le smic
plutôt que de vivre des aides sociales
elle incarne elle incarne la france que
nous voulons la france qui récompense et
encourage de travail au lieu de se
donner bonne conscience en distribuant
des chèques à ceux qui ne travaillent
pas penser à ces artisans assez
indépendant ces hommes et ces femmes à
la tête de leurs pme prisonniers des
charges des contrôles incessants et du
rsi
il est temps de les entendre il est
temps de construire une administration
qui n est pas une administration qui
sanctionne un modèle économique qui
attire et pas un modèle qui repousse
il est temps de donner nos entreprises
la liberté nécessaire pour créer de la
richesse et des emplois pour la france
pensez à ces policiers
pensez à ces gendarmes à ces militaires
qui assurent notre sécurité sur notre
territoire face à la menace terroriste
le courage de ces policiers et de ses
militaires est le prix de notre liberté
et argi c'est votre regard
élargissez votre horizon penser à ces
ouvriers que les socialistes ont trahi
et qui le demandent que la
reconnaissance de leur mémoire de leurs
sacrifices et de leur talent pensez à
ces magistrats à ses enseignants à ces
intellectuels à qui nous avons tourné le
dos quand beaucoup nos rêves comme nous
que de mérite et de respect de la loi
pensez à ses fils et à ses filles
d'immigrés qui se sentent français par
toutes les racines de lorette par leur
langue par leur culture par leur amour
de notre histoire nationale
ces hommes et ces femmes sont avant tout
de france ils ont toute leur place dans
notre famille politique
alors ouvrons nos bras à tous ceux qui
veulent construire avec nous la décennie
du renouveau
qui voulant nous weight qui vole en wet
voilà la bonne question nous voulons
être des nations puissantes qui inspire
le respect nous voulons redevenir la
grande nation que nous avons été nous
voulons restaurer notre puissance
économique pour retrouver notre
puissance politique
nous sommes passés par est-il derrière
la grande bretagne
nous sommes la risée de monsieur cameron
eh bien nous repasserons devant la
grande-bretagne et en dix ans nous
serons la première puissance économique
de l'europe
il est temps de faire des choix décisifs
il est temps de tourner un électorat
d'état providence kenney à faible nous
voulons être une nation unie nous
refusons le communautarisme rampant qui
gagne nos villes et nos quartiers et qui
réduit en miettes dix siècles de notre
histoire nous réaffirmons ici des règles
simples en france les religions se
soumettre à la loi
les lois ne se soumettent pas à la
religion en france
la rue appartient aux citoyens la rue
n'appartient pas aux croyants en france
le visage des femmes est une fierté
chaque femme en france et marianne au
drapeau tricolore de bush sur les
barricades
nous revendiquons notre exception
nationale nous voulons être une nation
de culture une nation qui parle qui
pensent qu'ils créent qui inventent qu
inspire le respect aux puissants qui ne
ressemble à aucune autre nation et qui
pour cela attire encore à elle le reste
du monde
nous voulons réaffirmer notre
indépendance contre tous ceux qui
veulent faire disparaître la france dans
un monde globalisé et aseptisé nous
défendons le latin parce que nous
défendons les racines de notre langue et
que demain sur le continent africain
la france sera sa langue nous défendons
les lumières parce que nous voulons
réaffirmer notre liberté de nos pensées
et notre insolence face au totalitarisme
islamiste
nous défendons la clarté de la mémoire
contre la barbarie
antiste deux dash pas lui re était un
théâtre de beauté des ch
on a fait une scène de crime nous les
combattrons sans relâche par la
puissance de nos armes et de notre
culture
certains vous dis-je la république est
en danger
non c'est notre culture nationale qui
est toujours plus faible qu'en nous
renonçons à une certaine exigence colère
nous mettons à mal notre culture la
culture du mérite du savoir de la
transmission quand nous tolérons des us
et coutumes contraire aux valeurs notre
nation nous mettons à mal notre culture
la culture de la laïcité
il n'ya pas d'accommodement possible
avec la laïcité
quand nous nous alignons sur les états
du golfe
quand nous refusons de demander des
comptes à des états qui joue double jeu
avec les forces islamistes temps nous
combattons sur notre territoire nous
rognons notre culture diplomatique la
culture de l'universalité qui fait le
respect de la voix de la france dans le
monde
notre langue notre mémoire notre
créativité notre ingéniosité le savoir
faire de nos artisans la fulgurance de
nos chercheurs nos savants notre regard
universel notre esprit de tolérance
notre goût de la conquête autres
impertinence notre sens de la liberté
notre capacité de révolte sont nos
meilleures armes dans le monde de demain
elle nous rassemble elle nous donne ce
que nous avons perdu depuis si longtemps
la volonté de vivre ensemble et la
conscience de notre destin commun alors
utilisons notre culture
infirmant notre culture nationale
défendons notre culture de france dans
la décennie du renouveau que je vous
annonce notre culture nationale sera
notre force et la france sera notre cas
vive la république et vive le france